This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Every city in the world has something that makes it special, but the ones that really capture my imagination are the cities with distinctive forms of transportation. Venice has its canals, London its bright red double-decker buskets, and the twin cities of Minneapolis and St. Paul and the twin cities of Minneapolis and St. Paul have skyways. In both cities, downtowns, there are vast networks of climate-controlled pedestrian bridges that reach over the streets and connect a building to building on the second floor. Here's how Minnesota Senator Amy Klobuchar describes them. The skyways, of course, are the glass enclosed above ground tunnels that connect our buildings.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。世界上每一座城市都有其独特之处，但真正让我浮想联翩的，是那些拥有独特交通形式的城市。威尼斯有运河，伦敦有标志性的红色双层巴士，而明尼阿波利斯和圣保罗双子城则拥有空中连廊。在两座城市的市中心，交织着庞大的恒温人行天桥网络，它们高悬于街道之上，在二楼将一栋栋建筑连接起来。明尼苏达州参议员埃米·克洛布查尔是这样描述它们的：“空中连廊，当然就是连接我们建筑的玻璃封闭式地上通道。”
Because if you go outside in the winter, you will die. That's right. And they're like a human habit trail. Habit trail is the brand name of literal hamster tubes, and that's a pretty good description. That's reporter and Minneapolis lifer, Katie Thornton. Walk along almost any downtown street in the Twin Cities and you'll see a series of these enclosed glass bridges tying together huge office buildings and shopping centers. Thanks to the skyways, you can park in a heated garage, go into work, run some errands,
因为如果你在冬天出门，你会冻死。没错。它们就像是人类的宠物鼠管道。宠物鼠管道就是仓鼠管的字面品牌名，这形容得相当贴切。这是记者兼明尼阿波利斯本地人凯蒂·桑顿的话。走在双子城市中心的几乎任何一条街道上，你都会看到一连串这样的封闭式玻璃桥，将巨大的办公楼和购物中心连为一体。多亏了空中连廊，你可以把车停在有暖气的车库里，去上班，办点杂事，
maybe go to the gym, all in short sleeves, on a minus 20 degree day. People legitimately brag about how many weeks they can go without stepping foot outside. Downtown Minneapolis has the oldest and largest contiguous Skyway network in the world. There are nearly 10 miles of totally enclosed climate-controlled pedestrian bridges, and Downtown St. Paul has its own massive system. The Skyways are integral to the Twin Cities sense of self. Amy Klobuchar was made miss Skyway of March 1988, for which she was awarded a free month's worth of jazz or size classes and an 8x10 color portrait from a Skyway Accessible Photography Studio. There's also the time the St. Paul Skyway system was turned into a mountain bike race course.
甚至去健身房，在零下二十度的天气里，全程都可以穿着短袖。人们绝对会吹嘘自己有多少个星期可以脚不沾地、不用走到户外。明尼阿波利斯市中心拥有世界上最古老、规模最大的连续空中连廊网络。这里有近10英里完全封闭、恒温的人行天桥，而圣保罗市中心也有自己庞大的系统。空中连廊是双子城自我认同不可或缺的一部分。埃米·克洛布查尔曾被评为1988年3月的“连廊小姐”，为此她获得了一个月的免费爵士舞或健美操课程，以及一张由连廊直达摄影工作室拍摄的8x10英寸彩色肖像照。还有一次，圣保罗的空中连廊系统甚至被改成了一条山地自行车赛道。
The one mile course wound through narrow corridors down staircases around Cherpin turns, and you can see participants didn't hold these map. These are okay, we're told by the way." And then, as many Minnesotans of a certain generation will remind you, there's the 1992 Children's Hockey Movie masterpiece, The Mighty Ducks. There's this one beloved scene in particular, where Coach Emilio Estevez and his rag-tag team of kids meet downtown to train on rollerblades, also a Minnesota invention. The kids fly through the busy skyways, struggling to stay upright on their blades, while well-dressed
这条一英里的赛道蜿蜒穿过狭窄的走廊、下楼梯、绕过急转弯，你可以看到参赛者们并没有拿着地图。顺便告诉大家，这些地方其实还可以。”然后，正如某一代的许多明尼苏达人会提醒你的那样，还有1992年儿童冰球电影杰作《野鸭变凤凰》。其中有一个特别受人喜爱的场景，教练埃米利奥·埃斯特韦斯和他的乌合之众般的儿童球队在市中心会合，穿着轮滑鞋进行训练，这也是明尼苏达州的发明。孩子们在繁忙的空中连廊中飞驰，努力在鞋子上保持平衡，而衣着光鲜的、
shoppers with arms full of gift-wrapped packages leap out of the way. After all, who's inner tenured wouldn't want to whizz through a glittering matroclus in the sky? I think there's an initial love that comes from the skyways of Wonderment. People look at that and think, wow, this is so special. Bill Lindicki is an urban geographer and writer in the Twin Cities. Bill gives architectural tours of the skyways, and he says the visitors on his tours are just a firebly impressed. The whole Skyway system comes across as a grand, specific achievement. There's something marvelous and futuristic about the best parts of the Skyways, where you
怀抱包好的礼品盒的购物者们则吓得跳开。毕竟，谁的内心深处不想在天空中金光闪闪的微型大都市里呼啸而过呢？我认为最初对空中连廊的喜爱源于惊叹。人们看着它会想，哇，这太特别了。比尔·林迪基是双子城的城市地理学家和作家。比尔提供空中连廊的建筑导览，他说他导览团的游客同样惊叹不已。整个空中连廊系统给人一种宏大而独特的成就感。空中连廊最精彩的部分有一种奇妙而未来的感觉，在那里你
really feel like we as a society have transcended something, and especially in winter time that feels marvelous and triumphant. Futuristic. Triumphant. It sounds almost utopian. A cozy micro city within the city, where you and other twin citizens can look down at the icy street beneath you, smug in your short sleeves, and collectively laugh in the face
真的会觉得我们作为一个社会已经超越了某些东西，特别是在冬日里，这种感觉奇妙而又胜利。充满未来感。充满胜利感。听起来几乎像是乌托邦。城市中一个舒适的微型城市，你和其他双子城居民可以俯瞰脚下冰冷的街道，穿着短袖暗自得意，集体对冬天
of winter. There's just one problem. at least from Bill's perspective. Well, I hate them. I think that they make downtown almost unredeemable, and I really wish that we could start taking them down one by one. A lot of people love this guy ways, but others want them gone. In fact, over the years, architects and urban planners from all over the world have said that the Twin Cities need to tear the skyways down.
嗤之以鼻。只有一个问题。至少从比尔的角度来看是这样。嗯，我讨厌它们。我认为它们让市中心几乎无可救药，我真的希望我们能开始一根一根地把它们拆掉。很多人喜欢空中连廊，但也有人希望它们消失。事实上，多年来，来自世界各地的建筑师和城市规划师一直表示，双子城需要拆除空中连廊。
Bill and other skyway antagonists have plenty of reasons behind their opposition. For them, it has to do with who gets to be in the skyways and who doesn't. And also, what the skyways have done to harm the streets below. The skyways haven't always attracted this kind of criticism. In the beginning, long before people like Bel-Lintake turned against them, they were heralded as the salvation of a struggling downtown. In the 1950s, many apples, like many cities across the country,
比尔和其他反对空中连廊的人背后有充分的理由。对他们来说，这与谁能进入空中连廊、谁不能进入有关。还有，空中连廊对下方的街道造成了怎样的伤害。空中连廊并非一开始就招致这种批评。起初，早在像比尔·林迪基这样的人开始反对它们之前，它们被欢呼为拯救苦苦挣扎的市中心的救星。在20世纪50年代，明尼阿波利斯就像全国许多城市一样，
was trying to stay lively or even occupied in the post-war era of white flight. Downtown shops suffered as city residents began moving to the quiet expanse of the burbs. But on top of this national trend away from downtowns, Minneapolis retailers faced another challenge. In 1956, in a fancy new suburb, seven miles southwest of downtown Minneapolis, something happened that changed everything about how people shan't.
正试图在白人群飞的战后时期保持活力，甚至维持人口。随着城市居民开始搬向郊区安静开阔的土地，市中心的商店遭受了打击。但除了这种远离市中心的全国趋势之外，明尼阿波利斯零售商还面临着另一个挑战。1956年，在明尼阿波利斯市中心西南方七英里处的一个豪华新郊区，发生了一件事，彻底改变了人们购物的方式。
Minnesota, the Twin Cities, we are literally the birthplace of the enclosed mall. Allison Kaplan is a retail reporter and the editor-in-chief of Twin Cities Business magazine. And she says the world's first indoor climate- shopping mall in Edina, Minnesota took not just the twin cities but the world by storm. It was called Southdale Center. Let's be honest we all know it gets cold in Minnesota and so it was about creating this amazing experience where you could park, go inside and spend hours. Southdale had 74 stores across three stories. Plastic foliage promised greenery in all four seasons.
明尼苏达州，双子城，我们绝对是有顶购物中心的诞生地。艾莉森·卡普兰是零售业记者兼《双子城商业》杂志的主编。她说，世界上第一个室内恒温购物中心在明尼苏达州埃迪纳开业，不仅席卷了双子城，更轰动了全世界。它被称为索代尔中心。说实话，我们都知道明尼苏达很冷，所以这关乎创造这种奇妙的体验：你可以停车、走进去并度过几个小时。索代尔有横跨三层的74家商店。塑料绿叶植物承诺四季常青。
There was a center plaza called the Garden Court a perpetual spring featuring a 21-foot vertical birdcage. The place even had its own Christmas jingle. Everyone shopping at Southdale for Christmas. Shopping at Southdale is fun. had its own Christmas jingle. Southdale was an instant hit with consumers, and in the years that followed, a ring of indoor malls would come to surround Minneapolis and St. Paul. They're all called the Dales. So you have Ridgedale, Southdale, Brookdale.
这里有一个被称为“花园庭院”的中央广场，这是一个永恒的春天，里面有一个21英尺高的垂直鸟笼。这个地方甚至有它自己的圣诞顺口溜。每个人都在索代尔过圣诞节。在索代尔购物真有趣。拥有它自己的圣诞顺口溜。索代尔一经推出便大受消费者欢迎，在随后的几年里，一圈室内购物中心开始环绕明尼阿波利斯和圣保罗。它们的名字都以戴尔（Dale）结尾。所以你有里奇代尔、索代尔、布鲁克代尔。
There's probably more Dales I'm not remembering. Over the decades, more and more shoppers and businesses would decamp from the city to the suburban Oasis. But in the late 1950s, a loose alliance of Minneapolis developers, business owners, and city officials began formulating plans to lure people back to downtown. So they kind of threw lots of things at the wall to see what sticks. And they came up with a bunch of ambitious and sometimes wacky ideas, most of which never happened.
可能还有更多我不记得的戴尔了。几十年间，越来越多的购物者和企业从城市撤离，涌向郊区的绿洲。但在20世纪50年代末，明尼阿波利斯的一群开发商、商业业主和城市官员结成了一个松散的联盟，开始制定计划，吸引人们回到市中心。所以他们基本上是把很多方法都试了一遍，看看哪个管用。他们想出了一堆雄心勃勃、有时甚至有些古怪的想法，其中大部分从未付诸实践。
One proposal would have installed a bunch of pedestrian underpasses so that shoppers wouldn't have to contend with or contribute to downtown's horrible traffic problem. While an opposite proposal envisioned sinking all the thoroughfares below the ground level, so that the surface streets would be just for pedestrians. But the idea that ended up sticking was arguably the most ambitious and wacky of them all, and it was the brainchild of a far-sighted Minnesota named Leslie Park. Park, to me, epitomizes the wasp business type that Minneapolis
其中一个提议是修建一堆行人地下通道，这样购物者就不必面对或加剧市中心可怕的交通问题。而另一个相反的提议则设想将所有的交通干线沉入地下，这样地面街道就只供行人使用。但最终得以实施的想法可以说是其中最雄心勃勃也最古怪的一个，它是远见卓识的明尼苏达人莱斯利·帕克的心血结晶。在我看来，帕克是明尼苏达州闻名的盎格鲁-撒克逊新教徒商界类型的缩影。
was famous for. Park was one of the city's largest property holders and a strict religious conservative. For example, he owned hotels and restaurants, but he would set aside all of the income that he got from liquor sales and put them in a separate fund and give that to charity because he felt it was immoral to profit off of vice. It also appears that he didn't like the kinds of things that cities were associated with, like smells and crowds and street level chance encounters. So Park took a cue directly from the family-friendly suburbs in their clean indoor malls and added
帕克是该市最大的地产持有者之一，也是一名严格的宗教保守派。例如，他拥有酒店和餐厅，但他会把所有从酒类销售中获得的收入留作备用，存入一个单独的基金并捐给慈善机构，因为他觉得从恶习中获利是不道德的。他似乎也不喜欢城市通常伴随的气味、人群和街头偶遇等事物。因此，帕克直接借鉴了家庭友好型郊区及其清洁室内购物中心的做法，并增加了一个
a twist, an architectural innovation that would allow downtown shoppers to stroll from building to building without ever hitting the pavement. He got the city to grant him air rights, not just for the building he was constructing, but for the street in front of it. And once the building was finished, like a lot of other places downtown, it had a handful of stores on the first floor. It also has an almost 19th century Parisian arcade, style, second floor, except with silvery, glass and steel, ceilings and walls. And jutting out of the second floor shopping area was a big glass enclosed climate controlled bridge,
转折——一项建筑创新，可以让市中心的购物者在建筑物之间漫步，而无需踏上人行道。他让市政府授予他空间权，不仅针对他正在建造的建筑，还针对它前面的街道。一旦大楼完工，就像市中心的许多其他地方一样，它的一楼有几家商店。它还拥有一条近乎19世纪巴黎拱廊风格的二楼步行街，只不过天花板和墙壁换成了银色的玻璃和钢材。从二楼购物区突出来的是一座巨大的、玻璃封闭的恒温天桥，
the first skyway. A skyway that conveniently led to the second floor of another building that Leslie Park owned. And so what had been the second floor, the least valuable part of the building, is now more retail corridors that people can walk through and become as much more valuable than it used to be. And that transformation of the second floor into a space for pedestrians and workers would itself end up transforming the Twin Cities. It took a few years for everyone to catch on, but Leslie Park's Skyway eventually proved to be a win-win.
第一条空中连廊。这条空中连廊很方便地通往莱斯利·帕克拥有的另一栋建筑的二楼。因此，原本作为二楼——建筑中最不具价值的部分——现在变成了更多人们可以穿行的零售走廊，比以往任何时候都更有价值。而二楼向行人及工作者空间的这种转变，最终也将改变双子城。花了几年时间大家才接受，但莱斯利·帕克的空中连廊最终证明是一个双赢的结果。
Consumers discovered that it provided the indoor shopping experience they were clamoring for. While developers realized it potentially doubled the amount of space buildings could devote to retail. In the following decade, downtown building owners started making agreements with their neighbors across the street to build their own skyways, a process that only accelerated in 1972. I like to think of it as the moment where the Skyway system became sentient, where it achieved its own critical mass. That year, the IDS Center opened in downtown Minneapolis.
消费者发现它提供了他们梦寐以求的室内购物体验，而开发商则意识到它可能会使建筑用于零售的空间翻倍。在接下来的十年里，市中心的建筑业主开始与街对面的邻居达成协议，建造他们自己的空中连廊，这个进程在1972年进一步加速。我愿意把它视为空中连廊系统变得有意识、实现自身临界质量的时刻。那一年，IDS中心在明尼阿波利斯市中心开业。
Designed by Philip Johnson, it was the tallest building in the state, and soon radiating out in all four directions from its beautiful glass walled central shopping and dining court, or Skyways. They quickly became the city's central hub. That was kind of the moment that there was hope that okay, the entire Skyway system is going to come together so that you're not just going to one shopping area you could go to, you know, five blocks worth of shopping destinations without ever going outside, the suburbs can't compete with that.
由菲利普·约翰逊设计，它是当时该州最高的建筑，很快，从其美丽的玻璃墙中央购物和餐饮庭院向四个方向辐射出去的就是空中连廊。它们迅速成为城市的中央枢纽。那是一个充满希望的时刻，好吧，整个空中连廊系统将连为一体，这样你就不只是去一个购物区，你可以去，你知道的，相当于五个街区的购物目的地，而完全不用走到户外，郊区是无法与此竞争的。
In Minneapolis, Skyways became a given in any new construction, and impressed by the new indoor development in their sister city, St. Paul officials started developing their own city-run Skyway system. Everyone wanted to be on the second floor. Even classic downtown mom and pop shops and shoe shines moved to the skyway level and customers followed. Within a few years, the average downtown worker in Minneapolis and St. Paul was spending twice as much money as their counterpart in other cities during their lunch break. In the skyways, it was just so easy to buy things things uninterrupted. You could walk to the food court for lunch, get your shoes shined along the way, pick up a gift or a new watch, all without stopping for traffic or putting on your coat.
在明尼阿波利斯，空中连廊成为了任何新建建筑的标配，对其姐妹城市的新室内开发印象深刻的圣保罗官员也开始开发他们自己由城市运营的空中连廊系统。每个人都想去二楼。甚至市中心传统的夫妻老婆店和擦鞋摊也搬到了空中连廊层，顾客们也随之蜂拥而至。几年之内，明尼阿波利斯和圣保罗的普通市中心员工在午休期间花的钱是其他城市同行的两倍。在空中连廊里，买东西是如此轻而易举且连贯。你可以步行去美食广场吃午饭，顺便擦个鞋，挑一件礼物或买块新表，全程不用理会交通或穿上外套。
The cities had gone upstairs. But the skyways offered more than just a hypnotic ability to make workers spend more money. Everything that you would have on the ground floor was scattered throughout downtown at the Skyway level as well, which was awesome. James Garrett Jr. is an architect in downtown St. Paul. He lives and works in buildings connected by the Skyways. And as a kid in the 1980s, the Skyways were his happy place. Or as James would say, his awesome place.
城市搬到了楼上。但空中连廊带来的不仅仅是诱使工人们花更多钱的催眠能力。你在底层能拥有的一切，在空中连廊层也分散在市中心的各处，这太棒了。詹姆斯·加勒特·杰里在圣保罗市中心当建筑师。他在被空中连廊连接的建筑物中生活和工作。作为20世纪80年代的一个孩子，空中连廊是他的快乐天堂。或者用詹姆斯的话说，是他的好地方。
When I was growing up, there was a movie theater on the Skyway, which was awesome. There was a park connected to the Skyway with indoor plants and trees, and you could walk around and go up this ramp, and I mean, it was like a waterfall there, and it was awesome. In the Skyways, James would go to restaurants and pool halls and record stores, even a mini golf course.
当我长大的时候，空中连廊上有一家电影院，这太棒了。空中连廊还连接着一个公园，里面有室内植物和树木，你可以四处走走，走上这个坡道，我的意思是，那里就像有一个瀑布，太棒了。在空中连廊里，詹姆斯会去餐厅、台球厅、唱片店，甚至还有一个迷你高尔夫球场。
And beyond just the shops and parks, James' teenage architect brain was taken with the physical structures themselves. So after all the stores and restaurants had closed for the evening, he and his friends would meet up to explore every nook and cranny, finding the dead ends and the transfer points. And we're walking around, we're seeing how far we can go before it ends, and then, you
除了商店和公园，詹姆斯的青少年建筑师大脑还被实体结构本身深深吸引。因此，在所有的商店和他和朋友们在傍晚打烊后，会碰头探索每一个角落，寻找死胡同和换乘点。我们在四周走走，看看在它结束之前我们能走多远，然后，
know, can you get up and down to these doors open? How do you, you know, you're just figuring out the system? Even today, this guy ways can be hard to navigate, but James and the other kids knew the system better than anyone. So when James was 15, they were actually hired by the director of the Skyway YMCA. In the summer and on weekends, James and his friends would approach confused looking visitors with maps and pens and help them out. They had a booth.
你知道的，你能上下走动吗，这些门开着吗？你是怎么，你知道的，你只是在摸索这个系统？即使在今天，空中连廊也可能很难导航，但詹姆斯和其他孩子们对这个系统的了解比任何人都多。因此，当詹姆斯15岁时，他们实际上被空中连廊青年会的总监雇用了。在夏天和周末，詹姆斯和他的朋友们会拿着地图和笔，走向那些看起来很困惑的游客并提供帮助。他们有一个小摊位。
They even served as couriers, running packages across downtown through the Skyways, with no street lights or icy sidewalks to trip them up. And there's about ten of us, another African-American kid, couple of white kids from West Seventh Street, three or four Hmong kids, and it was like the best job ever. When they weren't working or catching a movie, they found secret skyway spots where they could watch the buses come in from all different directions.
他们甚至还充当信使，通过空中连廊把包裹送到市中心各处，没有交通信号灯或结冰的人行道绊倒他们。我们大概有十个人，另一个非裔美国小孩，七街的几个白人小孩，三四个苗族小孩，这简直是史上最棒的工作。当他们不工作或看电影时，他们会找到秘密的空中连廊地点，在那里他们可以观看从四面八方开进来的公交车。
And that came in handy, not just in the winter, but whenever they dressed up to go out for a party during the hot, muggy nights of summer. And so you've got your brand new shirt on, you got your little gold-haaring bone chain with your name on it, and you've got your fearless sneakers or whatever, and you know, you're doing your thing, and you don't want to be all sweaty, and all that kind of stuff when you get to the party. So you knew that if you could get in the building, you could go up into the skyway, it's climate controlled in there. And when the bus that you were trying to get on was close enough, then you could run down the escalator
这不仅在冬天派上用场，而且在夏天闷热的夜晚，每当他们盛装打扮去参加派对时也很有用。所以你穿上了崭新的衬衫，戴着刻有你名字的小金色鱼骨链，穿着无畏运动鞋什么的，你知道的，你在做着你自己的事，当你到达派对时，你可不想浑身是汗什么的。所以你知道，如果你能进到建筑里，你就可以走到空中连廊上，那里是恒温的。当你要坐的那辆公交车离得足够近时，你就可以跑下自动扶梯，
and get outside and get on the bus in time. James and his friends always showed up to parties looking unseasonably sharp. And it was all thanks to the Skyways. James left for college in 1990. And he says he honestly didn't give the skyways too much that while he was away. After all, it wasn't like they were going anywhere.
走到户外，及时坐上公交车。詹姆斯和他的朋友们去参加派对时总是打扮得不同寻常地帅气。这一切都要归功于空中连廊。詹姆斯于1990年去上大学。他说，他在外地期间老实说并没有太多想起空中连廊。毕竟，它们又不会搬走。
But I started to notice that by the time I came back in 1995 after I graduated and I moved back home that I would go downtown or whatever to get in the skyway and it was a different vibe. And there was just fewer people. There was just a lot fewer people. And it was a different vibe and there was just fewer people. There's just like a lot fewer people and you know it was pretty dead. James noticed there were a lot more white collar workers than there were kids from nearby neighborhoods. There was also an increased police and security presence to the point where the skyways stopped being fun or even comfortable especially for young black men like James.
但我开始注意到，当我1995年毕业搬回家时，我再去市中心或者其他地方走进空中连廊时，那里的氛围已经变了。人就是变少了。人真的少了很多。而且氛围变了，人就是变少了。就像人真的少了很多，你知道的，那里挺死气沉沉的。詹姆斯注意到，白领工人比附近街区的孩子多得多。警察和安保人员的存在感也增强了，甚至到了让空中连廊不再有趣、甚至不再舒适的地步，尤其是对像詹姆斯这样的年轻黑人男性而言。
And it was more, you know, everybody's kind of watching their back and, you know, looking side to side. And yeah, it was just, it was pretty clear that it was just like, we have to make the skyways feel safe for suburban people because that's what ultimately it was for. And of course, it's true. That was what the Skyways had always been for, away from property owners to lure people back from the suburbs by replicating what was working in suburban malls, like South
而且更多的是，你知道的，每个人都在提防着周围，东张西望。是的，这很明显，就像是，我们必须让空中连廊让郊区来的人感到安全，因为归根结底它们就是为此而建的。当然，这是事实。这正是空中连廊一直以来的用途：为地产业主提供一种方式，通过复制索代尔等郊区购物中心的成功经验，
Dale. But back in the era of white flight when the Skyways were built, those suburban malls hadn't been for just anyone. Suburbs would have de facto covenants that made it almost impossible for a person of color to buy a home. And so that was, it sort of set the tone for how suburbs grew in the Twin Cities. In the suburb of Adina, the very same place where the Southdale Mall was located. There were people who boasted as late as the 1960s that the town did not have a single block resident. But as the Twin Cities grew more diverse, James says the skyways were still trying to serve
把人们从郊区吸引回来。但在白人群飞、空中连廊建造的时代，那些郊区购物中心并不是为所有人服务的。郊区曾有事实上的契约，使有色人种几乎不可能买得起房。所以，这为双子城郊区的发展定下了基调。在埃迪纳郊区——正是索代尔购物中心所在地——直到20世纪60年代，还有人夸耀说该镇没有一个黑人居民。但随着双子城变得更加多元化，詹姆斯说空中连廊仍然试图迎合
their original white suburban demographic. And it was really, I think, in the 90s that the crackdown started to happen, maybe the mid 90s where it was made clear to us, by the way, that we were policeed, and by the way, that the security followed us around and profiled a lot of us that we weren't supposed to be there. It wasn't really for us. Even in the quote-unquote, good years, James says he and his friends were sometimes followed
它们最初的白人郊区客群。我想，打击行动确实是在90年代开始发生的，也许是90年代中期，当时通过种种方式向我们明确表态：我们被监视了，安保人员到处尾随我们，对我们很多人进行人脸识别和盘查，这意味着我们不应该呆在那里。这里其实不是为我们准备的。甚至在所谓的好日子里，詹姆斯说他和他的朋友们有时也会在商店里
in stores questioned by security guards, even shouted at, over loudspeakers. And so there was this tension between knowing that we weren't really wanted, but then, you know, sort of given a middle finger to that and saying, well, I'm going to be here anyway because I can be. And from the Skyways inception, well before James and his friends started feeling unwelcome, the Skyways had been keeping out a long list of other people who didn't fit the white collar suburban mold. There used to be a really big skid row in downtown Minneapolis that was located right by
被保安尾随、盘问，甚至通过扩音器大声呵斥。所以这种紧张关系一直存在：一方面知道自己并不是真正受欢迎的，但另一方面又对此竖起中指，心想：好吧，我无论如何都要在这里，因为我有资格。从空中连廊诞生之初，早在詹姆斯和他的朋友们开始感到不受欢迎之前，空中连廊就已经把许多不符合白领郊区标准的其他人拒之门外了。明尼阿波利斯市中心曾经有一个非常大的贫民窟，就位于
the public library. Bill Lindicki says that Skid Row was just one part of a historic downtown that's now been largely forgotten. Popular with itinerant workers coming in from surrounding areas, it featured rooming houses, bars, and a large public park. But between 1958 and 1965, the same period when Leslie Park was building the first skyway, just a few blocks away, the city of Minneapolis used federal money earmarked for urban renewal to get rid of Skid Row. So the Gateway Urban Renewal Project basically leveled all of the buildings from first street
公共图书馆旁。比尔·林迪基说，那个贫民窟只是现在已被大面积遗忘的历史市中心的一部分。这里深受从周边地区赶来的流动工人的喜爱，拥有合租公寓、酒吧和一个大型公共公园。但在1958年至1965年间——即莱斯利·帕克在几个街区外建造第一条空中连廊的同一时期——明尼阿波利斯市政府动用了拨给城市更新的联邦资金，彻底铲除了这个贫民窟。因此，门户城市更新项目基本上平毁了从第一街到
to six or eight blocks to the east. And without exception, every historic building in that area got got torn down. In the end, one third of downtown Minneapolis was demolished, including the bark, and replaced with more office buildings. The other thing it was replaced with was lots and lots of parking, so if you look at photos from this period, you'll see one or two modern office buildings, and then you'll see blocks and blocks of service parking lots next door. And a lot of these parking lots were connected to the office buildings by skyways, meaning commuters never needed to set foot near a rowdy bar or a panhandler if they didn't want to. So the Skyways were a place to escape the weather. They're also a place to escape the old street life of downtown Minneapolis. Once it was assumed that new buildings would be connected
东边六八个街区之间的所有建筑。无一例外，该地区的所有历史建筑都被拆毁了。最后，明尼阿波利斯市中心的三分之一被夷为平地，包括那个公园，取而代之的是更多的办公楼。它还被大量大面积的停车场取代，所以如果你看这一时期的照片，你会看到一两栋现代办公楼，然后你会看到隔壁成片的服务性停车场。其中许多停车场通过空中连廊与办公楼相连，这意味着通勤者如果不想的话，永远不需要踏足喧闹的酒吧或乞丐附近。所以空中连廊是逃离恶劣天气的地方。它们也是逃离明尼阿波利斯市中心古老街头生活的地方。一旦新建筑被默认将在二楼连接，
on the second floor, architects and planners began a long trend of designing away from parks and outdoor areas, and toward indoor spaces. They turned their back on the street. Instead of facing the sidewalk, shops and new skyscrapers opened up on the inside, like at a mall. And since the Minneapolis skyways were privately owned, the developers had no obligation to be welcoming. The entrances to the system were often obfuscated in high-end hotels or expensive street-level stores. People complained all the time about how it was hard to get in and out, but this was seen as a feature not a bug by many people in the skyway system, because it also kept out folks you maybe didn't want to have in your office buildings or in your department stores.
建筑师和规划师便开始了一种长期的设计趋势：背对公园和户外区域，转向室内空间。他们背对街道。商店和新的摩天大楼不再面向人行道，而是像商场一样向内部开放。由于明尼阿波利斯的空中连廊是私有的，开发商没有义务表现得热情好客。该系统的入口往往隐藏在高端酒店或昂贵的临街商店中。人们总是抱怨进出有多么困难，但在空中连廊系统中的许多人看来，这是一个特性而不是缺陷，因为它也将你可能不希望出现在办公楼或百货公司里的人挡在了外面。
Every now and then architectural consultants hired by one of the cities would suggest ways to improve skyway access. But some property owners said easier entrances would bring the so-called wrong element into the skyways. Others said there just wasn't enough money. And there are multiple sketches through the years of, you know, staircases coming down to the street
由其中一个城市雇用的建筑顾问会不时提出改善空中连廊通达性的方法。但一些业主表示，更便利的入口会将所谓的“不良分子”引入空中连廊。其他人则表示资金根本不够。多年来，有多个草图展示了（你知道的）从空中连廊通往街道的楼梯，
from the skyways that just never materialized. If you went into downtown Minneapolis, you could see people walking directly above you, but often have no clue how to get up there. And even if you did make it into the skyways, finding your way around could be an off-putting experience if you weren't a skyway person. It could be a maze,
但这些草图从未实现。如果你走进明尼阿波利斯市中心，你可以看到人们在你的头顶上方直接行走，但通常完全不知道该如何上去。即便你真的进入了空中连廊，如果你不是一个“连廊通”，找路也可能是一次令人沮丧的经历。它可能像个迷宫，
and if you didn't know how to get from the interior of one building with stores to another, you know, you could be walking around in that maze for hours. And there's almost nowhere to stop or pause or rest. There's very few benches, and there are unwritten rules to the skyways as a result. Even today, stopping in a skyway to look out the window or get your bearings
如果你不知道如何从一个开有商店的建筑内部走到另一个建筑内部，你知道的，你可能会在这个迷宫里转上好几个小时。而且几乎无处可停、可驻足或休息。长椅非常少，因此空中连廊有着不成文的规则。即使在今天，在空中连廊里停下来看看窗户或辨别方向，
can result in the people behind you walking right into you because you aren't really supposed to stop, or else they might give you a look as if you're not supposed to be there. In Minneapolis, the skyways have always been privately owned, an agreement between two buildings landlords, so lingering too long in the passageway can get you cited for trespassing on private property. St. Paul's system is technically public, but they still mostly connect privately owned
也可能会导致你身后的人直接撞到你身上，因为你其实不应该停下来，否则他们可能会给你一个眼神，仿佛你不属于这里。在明尼阿波利斯，空中连廊一直都是私有的，是两栋建筑房东之间的一项协议，所以在通道里逗留太久可能会因私闯民宅而被传讯。圣保罗的系统在技术上是公共的，但它们主要还是连接着私有的
office buildings and shopping centers, and are monitored by both private security and police. So in practice, the two city systems have both grown to feel like restricted spaces that aren't particularly welcoming to anyone besides the downtown's mostly white, mostly white collar commuters. In one infamous incident from recent years, the St. Paul Police stopped and tased a black man,
办公楼和购物中心，并受到私人保安和警察的双重监控。所以在实践中，这两座城市的系统都已经让人感觉像是受限制的空间，除了市中心那些主要是白人、主要是白领的通勤者之外，对其他人并不算特别欢迎。在近年来的一起臭名昭著的事件中，圣保罗警察拦下一名黑人男子并对他使用泰瑟枪，
picking up his two children from their skyway-connected daycare for sitting on a bench in the lobby of an office building. You know, they literally like filed him and chased him down through like two different skyways and he wasn't doing anything. And that's the fundamental problem with the skyways. Are they for everyone or are they just for certain people in the city? And that fundamental problem hasn't just impacted the people being kept out. Because over time, as the skyways grew less appealing to anyone who didn't work there, anyone who didn't work there, stop going.
当时他正从与空中连廊相连的日托中心接他的两个孩子，原因只是因为他在一栋办公楼的大厅长椅上坐了一下。你知道的，他们 literalmente 像追踪并追捕他穿过了两座不同的空中连廊，而他什么也没做。这就是空中连廊的根本问题所在。它们是为所有人服务的，还是只为城市里的某些人服务的？而这个根本问题不仅影响了那些被拒之门外的人。因为随着时间的推移，空中连廊对任何不在那里工作的人失去了吸引力，不在那里工作的人，
In the early 90s, fewer people began using the skyways to do weekend shopping or enjoy nighttime entertainment, just as building owners became less inclined to attract non-workday crowds. So James, back from college on school breaks, watched as most of the evening-oriented attractions that he and his friends had loved, began to disappear. The mini-golf plays closed. The pool hall that used to play cool music. That place closed. Then the movie theater is shuttered.
便不再前往。在90年代初，随着建筑业主越来越不愿意吸引非工作日的人群，较少有人开始使用空中连廊进行周末购物或享受夜间娱乐。因此，从大学放假回家的詹姆斯看着他和朋友们曾经喜爱的绝大多数夜间娱乐场所开始消失。迷你高尔夫球场关门了。那个常放酷炫音乐的台球厅。那个地方关门了。接着电影院也倒闭了。
I think for me that was just the one that I was just like, oh man, I can't close on the theater or what? You can't do that. Oh, and remember the indoor park, the one with the waterfall? I also went there, I remember it fondly. It's now abandoned and the glass ceiling is leaking and there's a sign that says no trespassing
我想对我来说，那是唯一让我觉得，天哪，影院怎么能关门呢？这怎么行。哦，还记得那个室内公园吗，那个有瀑布的公园？我也去过那里，我至今记忆犹新。它现在已经被废弃了，玻璃天花板在漏水，挂着一块写着“禁止通行”的牌子，
and they've sealed it off with a couple of cones. So it's all gone. Today, this guy weighs mostly catered to the 95 crown with shops that close by six and restaurants that serve only lunch. In Minneapolis Minneapolis most of the skyways themselves close by early evening and as for life on the first floor. What's left on this sheep's loat? You have your parking ramps, smokers, bus stops. not much else to be honest.
他们用几个锥形路标把它封锁了。所以一切都消失了。如今，空中连廊主要迎合朝九晚五的白领阶层，商店六点前就关门，餐馆只提供午餐。在明尼阿波利斯，大多数空中连廊本身在傍晚早些时候就会关闭，至于一街之隔的地面生活。这条街上还剩下什么？只有你的停车坡道、吸烟者、公交车站。说实话，没别的了。
This might be the ultimate irony of the Skyways. They were never intended to be equitable spaces, but developers had intended for them to save downtown retail. Only the revitalization never materialized. Because even if the Skyways weren't popular enough to keep people downtown in the evenings, they were popular enough to keep them away from street level businesses during the day. Even on sunny days, hundreds of thousands of people would stay inside the skyways, and as more businesses move to the second floor, the streets below grew eerily still.
这也许就是空中连廊的终极讽刺。它们从一开始就不是为了成为公平的空间而建的，但开发商本意是想用它们拯救市中心的零售业。只是振兴从未真正实现。因为即使空中连廊不够受欢迎，无法让人们在傍晚留在市中心，但它们却足够受欢迎，在白天把人们吸引开，让他们远离街面层的商业。即便在阳光明媚的日子里，成千上万的人也依然呆在空中连廊里，随着越来越多的企业搬到二楼，下方的街道变得诡异地寂静。
By the mid-1980s, 90% of St. Paul's retail was on the second story, leaving the first floor of the city, gutted. And then the Mall of America opened. If Southdale's center was a disaster for the downtowns, the opening of the Mall of America in 1992 was like Armageddon. It was one of the largest downtowns, the opening of the Mall of America in 1992 was like Armageddon. It was one of the largest malls in the world. As of today, it's the largest in North America, and it attracted consumers in record numbers. This time, even Minneapolis's most beloved fictional characters abandoned the Skyways. When the Mighty Ducks 2 came out,
到20世纪80年代中期，圣保罗90%的零售业都集中在二楼，导致该市的一楼被掏空。接着美国商城开业了。如果索代尔中心对市中心是一场灾难，那么1992年美国商城的开业简直就像是世界末日。它是世界上最大的市中心之一。如果索代尔中心对市中心是一场灾难，那么1992年美国商城的开业简直就像是世界末日。它是世界上最大的商场之一。时至今日，它依然是北美最大的商场，并以创纪录的人数吸引着消费者。这一次，就连明尼阿波利斯最受喜爱的虚构角色也抛弃了空中连廊。当《野鸭变凤凰2》上映时，
the new film featured a scene of the team rollerblading not through the Skyways, but through the Mall of America, right in front of the mall's very own indoor roller coaster. Between the Mall of America and the Moruban streets, a lot of the high-end shops in downtown Minneapolis couldn't hold on. And the downtown closures have continued through the 90s, the early 2000s, and up to the
这部新电影里的一个场景是，队员们不是在空中连廊里滑轮滑，而是在美国商城里滑，就在商城自己的室内过山车前。在美国商城和摩尔人街道之间，明尼阿波利斯市中心的许多高端商店无法支撑下去了。市中心的倒闭潮在90年代、2000年代初一直延续到了
present. Pratin Barrel and Polo Ralph Lauren and Saxvifth Avenue and Neiman Marcus, and they're all gone. They're all gone. They're all gone. The most recent big one came in 2017. When downtown Minneapolis's last classic department store, Macy's also closed down. Which is really a blow to have a downtown without a department store, right?
现在。Crate & Barrel、Polo Ralph Lauren、Saks Fifth Avenue和Neiman Marcus，它们全都不见了。全都不见了。全都不见了。最近的一次大撤离发生在2017年。当时明尼阿波利斯市中心最后一家经典的百货公司梅西百货也关门了。拥有一个没有百货公司的市中心，这真是一个沉重的打击，对吧？
You're just kind of like one of those pillars of a city. Losing Macy's wasn't a specially hard hit, because it was housed in the building that at once those pillars of a city. Losing Macy's wasn't especially hard hit, because it was housed in the building that had once been Minneapolis's premier homegrown department store, Dayton's. The store had anchored downtown shopping since the early 1900s.
你就有点像是城市支柱之一。失去梅西百货并不是特别沉重的打击，因为它坐落在一栋曾拥有市中心支柱地位的建筑里。失去梅西百货并非特别沉重的打击，因为它曾是明尼阿波利斯最顶级的本土百货公司——代顿百货（Dayton's）的所在地。这家商店自20世纪初以来一直是市中心购物的支柱。
Allison was so upset by the store's closure that she actually tried to save it. She publicly asked her friend, Eric Dayton, whose family had owned the original store, if they would buy back the building and turn it into a modern mix of retail and restaurants. An Eric Dayton responded on Twitter and said, I will buy the building alley if you tear down the skyways.
艾莉森对这家店的倒闭感到非常沮丧，以至于她实际上试图拯救它。她公开请求她的朋友埃里克·代顿（Eric Dayton）——其家族曾拥有最初的那家店——是否愿意买下这栋建筑，把它变成零售和餐厅的现代混合体。埃里克·代顿在推特上回应说：“艾莉，如果你把空中连廊拆了，我就把这栋建筑买下来。”
Taring down the skyways isn't something Allison can do. Technically, it's up to all the individual property owners who have skyways connecting their buildings and Minneapolis. In St. Paul, it's up to the city government. But in both cities, the process would be long, hard, and bureaucratic. But try telling that to Bill Lindicki.
拆除空中连廊并不是艾莉森能做到的事情。从技术上讲，这取决于明尼阿波利斯所有拥有连接其建筑的空中连廊的个人业主。在圣保罗，则取决于市政府。但在两座城市，这个过程都将是漫长、艰难且官僚主义的。不过，你去对比尔·林迪基说这话试试看。
We could flood them all and turn them into aquariums. That would be interesting. Bill thinks that unless they're removed, the Twin Cities skyways will continue to wreak havoc on their downtowns. I think the skyways harm the most appealing thing about a downtown, which is its density, its diversity, its connectivity, and the idea that you could go there
我们可以把它们全淹了，然后把它们变成水族馆。那会很有意思。比尔认为，除非被拆除，否则双子城的空中连廊将继续对它们的市中心造成浩劫。我认为空中连廊破坏了市中心最具吸引力的特质，那就是它的密度、多样性、连通性，以及你可以去那里
and discover something new. And it's just so much harder to do any of that with a skyway system in place. Meanwhile, there are plenty of bustling neighborhoods in the Twin Cities known for their culture, attractions, and street life, even in winter. Proving that Minnesotans will spend time outside in the cold weather you've given a chance. They might even spend that time outside in shorts. Those people are crazy.
并发现新事物的理念。而一旦有了空中连廊系统，这一切就变得难得多。与此同时，双子城有许多充满活力的街区，以其文化、景点和街头生活而闻名，即使在冬天也是如此。这证明了只要有机会，明尼苏达人也愿意在寒冷的天气里在户外度过时光。他们甚至可能穿着短裤在户外度过这段时光。这些人疯了。
But for now, people like Bill, who want to tear down the Skyway system, face a steep uphill battle. Because for all their faults, the Skyways remain popular. Very few people agree with me about this. You talk to people who work or live downtown Minneapolis or just visit from time to time and everyone loves the skyways. The lonely life, the building decay. I've been trying to talk about it for years and years and years and I haven't gotten
但就目前而言，像比尔这样想要拆除空中连廊系统的人面临着一场极其艰难的战斗。因为尽管空中连廊有种种缺点，它们依然很受欢迎。在这件事上很少有人同意我的看法。你和在明尼阿波利斯市中心工作、生活或只是偶尔来访的人谈谈，每个人都喜欢空中连廊。冷清的生活，建筑的衰败。我多年来一直试图谈论这个话题，但
very far with convincing people that they're bad for the city. So I'm not super optimistic about it. I'm very practical and so my first thought was, I mean, that's not going to happen. Allison Kaplan doesn't see the skyways being torn down anytime soon, but she also doesn't personally want to see them go. She does have critiques, but like the overwhelming majority of folks who work downtown, Allison isn't ready to give up the perennial ease of the Skyway system. Let's be honest, through the Skyway,
在说服人们它们对城市有害方面并没有取得多大进展。所以我对此并不超级乐观。我很务实，所以我的第一反应是，我的意思是，那是不可能的。艾莉森·卡普兰并没有看到空中连廊在短期内被拆除的迹象，但她个人也不希望它们消失。她确实有批评意见，但就像在市中心工作的绝大多数人一样，艾莉森并不准备放弃空中连廊系统长青的便利性。老实说，通过空中连廊，
I can get to my closest coffee place in like two seconds. If I had to go down to the street level, that would take longer. So it just becomes a convenience that people might understand in the bigger picture. Overall, isn't serving us well, but to give up that convenience, nobody wants to do that.
我可以在大约两秒钟内到达我最近的咖啡店。如果我不得不走到地面层，那会花更长的时间。所以它成了一种人们可能在宏观层面上理解的便利。总的来说，它对我们服务得并不好，但要放弃这种便利，谁都不愿意这么做。
And for some, it's not just about convenience. For those with limited mobility, it can be a lot easier to walk in the skyways than on the icy sidewalks in the wintertime. So many people in the disability community advocate for more and better access to the skyways, instead of tearing them down. But perhaps the skyways' most surprising defender is an architect. St. Paul's own, James Garrett Jr. On one hand, there's the intellectual urban design, trained architect side of me that's
对某些人来说，这不仅仅关乎便利。对于行动不便的人来说，在冬季，走在空中连廊里可比走在结冰的人行道上要容易得多。因此，残疾人社区中的许多人主张获得更多、更好的空中连廊通行权限，而不是拆除它们。但也许空中连廊最令人意外的捍卫者是一位建筑师。圣保罗本土的詹姆斯·加勒特·杰里。一方面，我身上有受过训练的建筑师那种理性的城市设计思维，
I guess technically we're not supposed to like the Skyways and technically yes they siphon activity and life off of the street and blah, blah, blah. But I think there's a ton of potential. James knows the skyways, maybe better than anyone. He's lived and worked in skyway-connected buildings for years, so he knows they're not perfect. He's had white folks stop his sons and ask what they're doing there.
我想从技术上讲，我们不应该喜欢空中连廊，从技术上讲，是的，它们从街道上抽走了活力和生机，等等等等。但我认为这里面蕴含着巨大的潜力。詹姆斯对空中连廊的了解也许比任何人都多。他在与空中连廊相连的建筑里生活和工作多年，所以他知道它们并不完美。他曾遭遇白人拦住他的儿子们，质问他们在那里做什么。
But unfortunately, he says that's not a problem that's limited to the skyways. I mean, that could be, we could be in any park and barbecue and have someone do the same thing. Or I mean, it could be anything in this country, in this moment. Which is why James believes that any solution to downtown's problems should involve the skyway system.
但遗憾的是，他说这不是空中连廊所独有的问题。我的意思是，这可能会发生，我们可能在任何公园里烧烤，然后遇到有人做同样的事。或者我的意思是，此时此刻在这个国家的任何地方都可能发生这种情况。这就是为什么詹姆斯相信，任何解决市中心问题的方案都应该涉及空中连廊系统。
Not get rid of it. I would love for someone to fill those bad boys up with activities and with people, with senior citizens, with teenagers, and rethink and reimagine them. So yes, they might not be the world's best-thought-out piece of urban planning. But as someone that grew up with the Skyway and who's raised kids that have been in the Skyway, having their strollers being pushed the Skyway or racing each other through the Skyway, literally their entire lives and they don't know any different.
不是说要废弃它。我很乐意看到有人用活动、用人、用老年人、用青少年把这些坏小子们填满，重新思考并重新构想它们。所以是的，它们可能不是世界上考虑得最周全的城市规划。但作为和天空步道一起长大、养育的孩子也在天空步道里呆过的人，他们的婴儿车被推过天空步道，或者在天空步道里赛跑，几乎可以说是他们的整个一生，他们不知道还有什么别的样子。
I see what the potential could be and I think the Skyways are deserving of of some love and a second chance to be awesome again. So whether we're stuck with the skyways or someday somehow they come down, it looks like we'll only benefit if we try something we've never really done before. Designing the city for the city in all its vibrancy, variety, and splendor.
我看到了潜力的可能，我认为天空步道值得一些关爱，值得拥有第二次机会再次变得了不起。所以，无论我们是被困在天空步道中，还是有一天它们以某种方式被拆除，看起来我们只有在尝试一些以前从未真正做过的事情时才能受益。为城市本身的活力、多样性和辉煌来设计城市。
When we come back from the break, we'll talk about how the segregated architecture of the skyways fits into our present moment of reckoning with police violence and racial injustice. stay with us. So, I'm back with Katie Thornton. Katie, you and I wanted to talk about how things like the Skyways and divisive urban planning ties to this present moment with the killing of George Floyd and so many others and The reckoning in the aftermath. Yeah, so our city has been in really deep grief since the most recent Minneapolis police killing of Delal Id and since the May 2020 murder of George Floyd and far prior to these two Unfortunately, these lives were part of a long history
当我们从广告休息回来后，我们将讨论天空步道的隔离式建筑风格如何契合我们当前面对警察暴力和种族不公清算的时刻。请继续收听。那么，我回到了与凯蒂·桑顿（Katie Thornton）的对话中。凯蒂，你和我想要探讨诸如天空步道和分裂性城市规划是如何与当下乔治·弗洛伊德（George Floyd）等人的遇害以及余波中的清算联系在一起的。是的，自从明尼阿波利斯警察最近杀害德拉尔·伊德（Delal Id）以及2020年5月乔治·弗洛伊德遇害以来，我们的城市一直处于极度的悲伤之中，而且在这两起事件之前很久，不幸的是，这些生命都是一段漫长历史的一部分。
of police killings in my home city. So before these recent murders and corresponding uprisings and especially after, I wanted to look at how divisive urban designs like the Skyways intersect with policing in the Twin Cities. So I talked to DA Bullock. He is a filmmaker and a storyteller, community activist, and he's a police abolitionist. And he moved to Minneapolis 10 years ago. And I didn't know a lot about Minneapolis prior to it.
在我家乡发生的警察杀戮事件的一部分。所以在这些最近的谋杀案及相应的起义之前，尤其是之后，我想看看像天空步道这样分裂性的城市设计是如何与双城地区的警务工作交织在一起的。所以我采访了DA·布洛克（DA Bullock）。他是一位电影制作人、故事讲述者、社区活动家，也是一名废警主义者。他在10年前搬到了明尼阿波利斯。在此之前，我对明尼阿波利斯了解不多。
I may have visited it once. You know, I knew about Prince. But there was like a depth of knowledge about Minneapolis and the Twin Cities in general. And a quit, most people know about the Twin Cities is prints and maybe the skyways, if my email inboxes is any indication. Right. Yeah. And, you know, prints was part of this massively influential Minneapolis sound movement,
我可能去过那里一次。你知道的，我知道普林斯（Prince）。但对于明尼阿波利斯以及整个双城地区，并没有那种深度的了解。而大多数人对双城的了解就是普林斯，如果我的收件箱能说明问题的话，也许还有天空步道。没错。是的，而且，你知道的，普林斯是这个具有巨大影响力的明尼阿波利斯之声运动的一部分，
which was led by a ton of different black musicians, which not everybody talks about as much. A lot of people think that the Twin Cities are really white and homogenous, but that's not true. And DA saw that right away when he moved here. So what struck me first was that there was great diversity amongst the people,
该运动由一大批不同的黑人音乐家领导，并不是每个人都经常谈论这一点。很多人认为双城地区非常白且单一，但事实并非如此。DA搬到这里时，立刻就发现了这一点。所以最让我吃惊的是，人们之中有着巨大的多样性，
but I didn't see that reflected in the downtown. You didn't see the multiple Somali restaurants or the multiple among restaurants or those kinds of things of touchstones We use when we think about culture. But the lack of diversity and vibrance downtown Also has to do with security and policing and not just in the skyways the problems totally extend to the streets as well So D.A. and I talked about how there's this sort of boogie man of downtown And I talked about how there's this sort of boogie man of downtown crime. Like in a lot of the metro areas imagination, downtown is a particularly dangerous place to be
但我并没有看到这种多样性在市中心得到反映。你没有看到多家的索马里餐厅、多家的苗族餐厅，或者我们在思考文化时使用的那些触媒点。但市中心缺乏多样性和活力，也与安全和警务有关，而且不仅仅是在天空步道里，这些问题完全也延伸到了街道上。所以DA和我讨论了市中心存在的那种“妖怪”般的形象。并且我谈到了我们如何看待市中心的犯罪怪物。在许多大都市居民的想象中，市中心是一个特别危险的地方，
just walking around. And then, you know, politically, that's always one of the red meat talking points is our downtown is not safe. Even though the data really doesn't does them back that up at all, like it's been the safest that it's ever been, and it's been declining for years. And so every instance that they're treating as the norm is really the exception. And this is the case for a lot of American cities. I mean, stats don't support the idea
仅仅是走在周围。然后，你知道的，从政治上讲，这总是那些煽动性的谈话要点之一，即我们的市中心不安全。尽管数据根本不支持这一点，它其实是有史以来最安全的，而且这种趋势已经持续下降多年。因此，他们把每一个当作常态来对待的事件，实际上都只是特例。对于许多美国城市来说都是如此。我的意思是，统计数据根本不支持这种观点
of cities and downtowns being particularly dangerous places at all. Yeah, absolutely. And I do think it's important to acknowledge that there has been a recent uptick in crime here in the past year, just as there's been in a lot of cities. And I don't want to minimize the crime that does take place. But up until relatively recently, crime had been on a steady decline for years and years in the Twin Cities. Like in 2018 many types of crime were at a 30-year low in Minneapolis. And so what do you think that people continue to believe that these are particularly dangerous places? Well, I think it's largely because of how the streets
即城市和市中心是特别危险的地方。是的，绝对如此。而且我确实认为，承认过去一年里这里的犯罪率最近有所上升是很重要的，就像许多城市一样。我不想尽量缩小确实发生的犯罪行为。但在相对最近之前，双城地区的犯罪率多年来一直在稳步下降。比如在2018年，明尼阿波利斯的许多犯罪类型都处于30年来的最低点。那么你认为为什么人们继续相信这些是特别危险的地方？嗯，我认为这主要取决于街道的治安管理方式。
are policed. So that same year that a lot of crime was at a 30-year low. The Minneapolis Police Department started cracking down on things like loitering and spitting, like loud music and low-level drug possessions, things that happen all the time that can be very selectively enforced. Right. Like a speed trap. Like they could point to citations and arrests and fines of minor offenses and kind of create this narrative that the downtown was unsafe and that these actions were making it safer.
所以在犯罪率处于30年低点的同一年，明尼阿波利斯警察局开始打击诸如流浪和随地吐痰、大声音乐和低级别毒品持有等事情，这些事情一直在发生，并且可以被非常有选择性地执法。没错。就像一个超速陷阱。他们可以指出轻微违法行为的传票、逮捕和罚款，并以此营造出一种叙事，即市中心是不安全的，而这些行动正在让它变得更安全。
Right, exactly. Even though in the first place, there wasn't really a problem that they were trying to address. And so sort of in the same way that the debunked idea of broken windows policing in places like New York City opened the door for really discriminatory stop and
对，完全如此。尽管首先并没有真正存在他们试图解决的问题。因此，就像纽约市等地被揭穿的“破窗警务”理念为真正具有歧视性的拦路搜身政策打开了大门一样，明尼阿波利斯也发生了类似的事情。例如，当这种打击行动开始时，他们进行了一系列类似钓鱼执法清剿低级别大麻持有者的行动。被捕的47人中有46人是黑人。哦，天哪。我会说这令人难以置信，但对我来说这完全可以相信。被捕的七人中有黑人。哦，天哪。我会说这令人难以置信，但对我来说完全可以相信。
frisk policies, something similar happened in Minneapolis. So, for example, when this crackdown started, they did a series of almost like stings to bust people for low-level marijuana possession. And 46 out of the 47 people arrested were black. Oh, my God. I would say that's unbelievable, but it is totally believable to me. seven people arrested were black. Oh my God. I would say that's unbelievable, but it is totally believable to me.
（重复内容已在上一条体现）
Yeah, I mean, that's the painful thing about it. When you had those possession arrest downtown, not only did it give the false impression that crime was rising at the time, it also gave the impression that the people responsible for the supposed runaway crime were people of color and black folks in particular. Okay, so how did the skyways put into this picture of how downtown is pleased?
是的，我的意思是，这才是其中令人痛苦的地方。当你在市中心进行这些持有毒品逮捕时，它不仅给人一种当时犯罪率正在上升的错误印象，还给人一种印象，即造成所谓失控犯罪的责任人是有色人种，尤其是黑人。好的，那么天空步道是如何融入市中心治安管理这幅图景中的呢？
I mean, do we see that the skyways are something extension of what's happening on the surface streets? Well, yes, but I also think that the skyways add to the fantasy and fear of imagined downtown crime. Because if someone is already afraid of the streets, they can avoid them, and they don't have to walk on the sidewalks where they might have conversations and get to know people and have their real life experience
我的意思是，我们是否看到天空步道是地面街道上发生的事情的某种延伸？嗯，是的，但我也认为天空步道加剧了人们对市中心犯罪的幻想和恐惧。因为如果有人已经对街道感到害怕，他们就可以避开它们，他们不必走在人行道上，在那里他们可能会进行对话、结识他人，并让他们的现实生活经历
prove the racist fantasy otherwise. And people are worried that they're going to get mugged on the streets. And that's ironic, because one of the things that people in the skyways say is that the streets are too empty to feel safe. And it's like, well, yes, in part because the skyways have made them that way. So I think never going down to the street reinforces this cycle of unfounded fear, which is then even made worse by biased and violent policing. Yeah, so it's like this vicious cycle between the built environment and policing.
证明种族主义的幻想是错误的。人们担心他们会在街上被抢劫。这很讽刺，因为天空步道里的人们所说的事情之一就是街道太空旷了，感觉不安全。这就好像是，嗯，是的，部分原因正是因为天空步道让街道变成了那个样子。所以我认为，从不去到街道上会强化这种毫无根据的恐惧循环，而有偏见且暴力的警务工作又让这种恐惧雪上加霜。是的，所以这就如同内置环境与警务之间的一种恶性循环。
They just make a positive feedback loop that no one can break out of. Yeah, or like a negative feedback loop. Like, we see segregation ingrained in our built environment by things like the skyways, as well as things like the red lining that we mentioned in the story. And when police forces have been charged in part with safeguarding infrastructure and private property, that means they're safeguarding that structural racism. And that's sort of cooperation between urban planning and policing also plays out in another problem
它们只是形成了一个谁也无法打破的正反馈循环。是的，或者说是一个负反馈循环。就像我们看到隔离现象深深扎根于我们的内置环境一样，通过像天空步道这样的东西，以及我们在故事中提到的红线划定等事情。当警察部队被赋予部分保障基础设施和私人财产安全的职责时，这就意味着他们在维护结构性种族主义。城市规划和警务之间的这种合作，也在另一个问题上体现出来
with downtown and Minneapolis's urban planning. It's something that DA and I talked about. And that's the fact that for DA and his neighbors, it's still really hard to even get downtown. So, DA lives in North Minneapolis, which is where a lot of Minneapolis's black community lives. And geographically, North Minneapolis and downtown Minneapolis are extremely close within walking, biking, distance, close, right? So that's one thing that really makes the other thing stand out, which is how difficult it actually is to
明尼阿波利斯市中心和城市规划的问题。这是我和DA讨论过的事情。那就是对DA和他的邻居来说，甚至连去市中心都仍然非常困难。所以，DA住在北明尼阿波利斯，明尼阿波利斯的许多黑人社区都在那里。从地理上看，北明尼阿波利斯和明尼阿波利斯市中心极其接近，在步行、骑行的距离之内，非常近，对吧？所以这就是一件事，它让另一件事变得格外显眼，那就是实际上要去到
get downtown ten times more difficult than the actual geographic space. So like in a lot of other larger black neighborhoods in the US, the Northside has been cut off from downtown by physical barriers and also really highly polluting barriers, like in interstates, and an impound lot, and a trash incinerator. So, despite that it's really close, there's no straight shot downtown from the North side. It's all divided by something. Exactly. These big pieces of infrastructure. But in my conversation with DA, we also talked about something hopeful,
市中心比实际地理空间要困难十倍。就像美国许多其他较大的黑人社区一样，北区被物理屏障以及高度污染的屏障（如州际公路、扣车场和垃圾焚烧厂）与市中心隔离开来。因此，尽管它真的很近，但从北区却没有直达市中心的道路。到处都被某些东西分割了。没错。这些大型基础设施。但在我和DA的对话中，我们也讨论了一件充满希望的事情，
which is that people still do make their way to downtown Minneapolis. Because even though it might be pretty sleepy, people want to be in a downtown. Yeah, I remember James saying something similar, like back in the 80s, like, he and his friends just wanted to be downtown. No matter how difficult somebody made it, you know, they were going to be downtown.
那就是人们仍然会前往明尼阿波利斯市中心。因为尽管它可能相当冷清，但人们还是想要身处市中心。是的，我记得詹姆斯说过类似的话，比如在80年代，他和他的朋友们只是想去市中心。不管别人把它变得多么困难，你知道的，他们都要去市中心。
Absolutely. And DA sees the same thing happening today, especially with youth and younger people. Yeah. I mean, think about it when you were young, you still found a way to do what you wanted to do. Like, if all the action was happening somewhere else, you found a way to get there. And I think it's still like the bane of the city's design is how do we deal with these young people or these houseless people and you know all these kind of things that they don't necessarily say explicitly because often those people are predominantly people of color. So you mentioned that the DA is for abolishing the police in Minneapolis, but where does he land
绝对如此。DA看到今天也发生了同样的事情，尤其是对于年轻人和青少年。是的。我的意思是，想想看，当你年轻的时候，你仍然会找到办法去做你想做的事。就像如果所有的活动都在别处发生，你就会想方设法去到那里。我认为这仍然是城市设计的痛点所在：我们如何处理这些年轻人或这些无家可归的人，你知道的，所有这些他们不一定会明确说出来的事情，因为通常这些人主要是同有色人种。所以你提到DA支持废除明尼阿波利斯的警察，但他对
when it comes to Skyways? Like, is he like James Garrett, Jr., where he thinks they can be reformed or more with Bill Lindigay, where he thinks they should be filled with water internal aquariums? I mean, does he think that Skyway should be abolished too? You know, he didn't have any how it takes on the aquarium question, but the age, generally
天空步道持什么态度？比如，他像小詹姆斯·加勒特（James Garrett, Jr.）那样认为它们可以被改造，还是更倾向于比尔·林迪盖（Bill Lindigay）那样认为应该把它们装满水的室内水族馆？我的意思是，他也认为应该废除天空步道吗？你知道的，他对水族馆的问题没有什么看法，但DA总的来说
speaking, is more with Bill on this one. He thinks that there are some Skyways, like in hospitals that could stay up, but he finds the rest troubling, not just from a planning perspective, but from a symbolic perspective. Because when he came here 10 years ago, another thing he noticed right away was the skyways, and this is what he had to say about them. Just physically, it's such a intimidating, disinvitation, right? Like, you immediately look up over your head and you see people literally walking above you. That's not just a metaphor, that's like a real thing that seeps into your psyche of who belongs there and who doesn't.
在这个问题上更赞同比尔的观点。他认为有些天空步道，比如医院里的可以保留，但他觉得其余的都很令人不安，不仅从规划的角度来看，从象征意义的角度来看也是如此。因为当他10年前来到这里时，另一件他立刻注意到的事情就是天空步道，这是他对它们的评价：仅从物理上看，它就是这样一个令人恐吓、充满拒绝意味的东西，对吧？就像你立刻抬头往上看，看到人们真的在你的头顶上方行走。这不仅仅是一个隐喻，这是一个真实存在的、渗入你心智的东西，关于谁属于这里，谁不属于这里。
Yeah, I mean, that's the symbolism for almost the entire story and a nutshell. Yeah, totally that is like the whole thesis, so thank you, DA. Well, Katie, this has been really eye-opening. Thank you so much for bringing us the story and for talking with me. Thank you, Roman. You can learn more about Katie Thornton's work, including her original long form essay about the history of Skyways on Instagram at its Katie Thornton or at our website. It's Katie Thornton.com. So we sharing pictures and stories of specific Skyways, including many apples,
是的，我的意思是，这几乎是整个故事的象征意义的浓缩。是的，完全如此，这就是全部的主旨，所以谢谢你，DA。好的，凯蒂，这真的是让人大开眼界。非常感谢你给我们带来这个故事并与我交谈。谢谢你，罗曼。你可以了解更多关于凯蒂·桑顿的工作，包括她关于天空步道历史的原创长篇随笔，在Instagram上关注 @its Katie Thornton 或访问我们的网站 It Katie Thornton.com。我们将分享特定天空步道的照片和故事，包括明尼阿波利斯的
only used Skyway, which got moved from its original location to its present day one in a 1981 parade led by a vintage Rolls Royce with a jazz band playing a top-the-moving structure. Seriously, you cannot make this stuff up. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Katie Thornton Edited by Joe Rosenberg, mixed by Bryson Barnes, music by Sean Rial. Delaney Hall is our senior producer Kurt Colesady is the digital director.
唯一使用过Một的天空步道，它在1981年的一场游行中从原址被移动到了现在的地点，游行由一辆老式劳斯莱斯引领，爵士乐队在移动的建筑顶部演奏。说真的，你编不出这样的事。本周的 99% Invisible 由凯蒂·桑顿制作，乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）编辑，布赖森·巴恩斯（Bryson Barnes）混音，肖恩·里亚尔（Sean Rial）配乐。德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的高级制作人，库尔特·科尔萨迪（Kurt Colesady）是数字总监。
The rest of the team is Emmett Fitzgerald, Katie Mangle, Christopher Johnson, Abby Madon, Chris Baroube, Vivian Le, Sophia Klotzger, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which exists all around North America right now, but in its heart it will always be. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a part of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best most innovative shows in all
团队的其他成员是埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、凯蒂·曼格尔（Katie Mangle）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、艾比·马顿（Abby Madon）、克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroube）、维维安·勒（Vivian Le）、索菲亚·克洛茨格（Sophia Klotzger），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在 Radio Row 制作，这个地方现在存在于整个北美，但它的核心永远是美丽、市中心、加利福尼亚州奥克兰。我们是 PRX 旗下 Radio Topia 的一部分，这是一个由全美最优秀、最具创新性的节目组成的集体。
of podcasting. Discover, listen and support them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet to me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org on Instagram and Reddit too. But we have pictures of skyways and clips of the mighty ducks and the replacements. I know about the replacement song. You can hold on to that email. I know all about it. It's all at 99pi.org.
播客。在 radiotopia.fm 发现、收听并支持他们所有人。你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与有关该节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 @Roman Mars，也可以在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上@该节目 @99PI org。我们有天空步道的照片，还有《野鸭高校》（The Mighty Ducks）和 The Replacements 的片段。我知道 The Replacements 的歌。你可以保留那封电子邮件。我对它了如指掌。这一切都在 99pi.org。
Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Radio Tapio，来自 PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。